[Music]
have you guys heard of candy man
okay ready
candy man
candy man
candy man
one more
handyman
well we're still alive so
katrina
let's go
guys
wait i forgot my vape
i don't think you should
what are you doing
oh my god guys stop being so stupid
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is where it all began
the story of candy man
look after he walk around handing out
candy to the neighborhood kids
one day a couple of kids get razor
blades in their candy
police come around
that's when i saw the true face of fear
get on your knees hands hands
they beat him
tortured him
[Music]
a couple weeks later more razor blades
and more candy
he'd been innocent so he's real candy
man ain't he
candy man's the whole damn hive
if you're out here looking for candy man
you ask me
stay away
i feel really connected to this story
gone
right here in this neighborhood
the legend started uh-huh
and the legend is
if we say his name five times while
looking in the mirror we could summon
him summon the candy man hell no
[Music]
candy man anthony nose
candy man i don't want to get creeped
out in my new apartment before bed
black people don't need to be summoning
no i dare you don't say that he's like
you better not do that last one
you want to be a part of the story right
no
say his name
candyman
[Music]
anthony
anthony
anthony
are you okay
the hell is going on
this neighborhood is haunted
i think i made a mistake
i brought him back candyman isn't real
he told me
he has purpose for you
new to the neighborhood
you should say candyman say his name
[Music]
you